PLENTY OF NEWS TODAY. THANKS
IN LARGE PART TO THE FACT
THAT KYLE SHANAHAN AND JOHN
LYNCH SPOKE TO THE MEDIA
TODAY ABOUT THE TRADE THAT
WILL PUT THE 49ERS IN
POSITION CLEARLY TO DRAFT A
QUARTERBACK. THAT'S ONE BIG
TAKEAWAY. WE'RE GOING TO
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY HAD TO
SAY MILES, BUT IT'S OBVIOUS
BECAUSE
ON THE OBVIOUS THEY MOVED UP
TO NUMBER THREE TO GET A
QUARTERBACK IF THERE WAS ANY
DOUBT THERE SHALL BE NO DOUBT.
THEY'RE UP AT NUMBER THREE
TO GET A QUARTERBACK. THEY
ADMITTED IT PLAINLY TODAY IN
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE. THAT
IS WHAT THEY TRADED UP TO
NUMBER THREE OVERALL IN ORDER
TO DO THEY WANTED TO DRAFT A
QUARTERBACK. THEY WANT TO GET
SOMEBODY WHO CAN LEAD THEIR
FRANCHISE FOR THE NEXT
HOWEVER MANY YEARS AND AS
MUCH AS THEY KEEP TRYING TO
COMPLIMENT JIMMY GAROPPOLO
AND SAY WE BELIEVE IN JIMMY
AND ALL THESE NICE THINGS
OBVIOUSLY THEY
LIKE THEY HAVE TO UPGRADE AT
THE POSITION. OTHERWISE, YOU
DON'T DO WHAT YOU DID AND
THAT WAS OBVIOUS FROM THE
MOMENT THAT THE TRADE WAS
REPORTED. BUT YOU KNOW, I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH CREDIT WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM FOR
ADMITTING THAT BEFORE THE
PICK IS IN BUT THEY DID DO IT
TODAY. SO, YES, IT IS NOW
VERY CLEAR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE AND WHY THEY'VE DONE IT.
THERE'S NO DOWNSIDE IN
ADMITTING IT THEY DON'T MOVE
UP TO NUMBER THREE IF THEY'RE
NOT PERFECTLY HAPPY WITH
WHOEVER IS LEFT AFTER TREVOR
OFF THE BOARD AND IF FOR SOME
REASON
SOME REASON THERE'S A TEAM
OUT THERE THAT MUST HAVE MAC
JONES AND THE JETS ARE
WILLING TO GIVE UP ZACH
WILSON AND GET WHATEVER ELSE
THEY'RE OFFERED. SO SOMEONE
ELSE CAN GET MAC JONES 49ERS
TAKE ZACH WILSON, NO SKIN OFF
THEIR BUTTS. I MEAN, THAT'S
SO THEY'RE IN POSITION TO GET
LAWRENCE WILSON OR IF IT'S
JONES WHOEVER IT IS THAT THEY
MOVED UP THEREFORE THEY'RE
GOING TO GET ONE OF THOSE
THREE GUYS, AND THAT'S FINE
WITH THEM. THEY'RE WILLING TO
INVEST THREE FIRST-ROUND
PICKS AND A THIRD ROUND PICK
FOR THAT PLAYER. LET'S
HERE FROM SHANAHAN AND LYNCH
EARLIER TODAY REGARDING THE
TRADE AND REGARDING THE
SUPPOSED FRANCHISE
QUARTERBACK WHO AT SOME POINT
WILL NO LONGER BE ON THE TEAM,
YOU KNOW, WE BH SPOKE TO
TO JIMMY KYLE KYLE DID RIGHT
AWAY AND THEN I DID LATER IN
THE DAY. YOU KNOW, I THINK
THINK THE I'LL LET KYLE GO
AFTER THIS BUT YOU KNOW, THE
MESSAGE WAS WHAT WE WERE
DOING WHY WE WERE DOING IT
AND HOW HE IS VERY MUCH STILL
PART OF OUR PLANS AND YOU
KNOW, I'M NOT NOT GOING TO
YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE THOSE
SHOULD REMAIN PRIVATE BUT BUT
JIMMY HE WELCOMES COMPETITION
AND SO LIKE I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT AND KYLE YOU GO AHEAD.
YEAH, VERY SIMILAR, YOU KNOW
ONE OF GET IT TO JIMMY.
DEFINITELY BEFORE IT CAME OUT
SO CALLED HIM FIRST THING HAD
A GOOD CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW, IT'S OBVIOUSLY NO
ONE WANTS TO HEAR THAT AND I
KNOW THERE ISN'T WASN'T
TOTALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT LIKE
YOU'D EXPECT BUT JIMMY
HANDLE THE GREAT LIKE HE
ALWAYS DOES WE WERE VERY
STRAIGHT UP WITH EACH OTHER
THIS DOESN'T MEAN
MEAN THIS ISN'T CHANGE HIS
ANY OF HIS CIRCUMSTANCES
RIGHT NOW. I MEAN YOU STILL
COMING IN HERE AND TRYING TO
LEAD THIS TEAM. I TOLD HIM
HOW EXCITED I WAS AT FREE
AGENCY WENT A LOT BETTER THAN
WE ANTICIPATED WITH BEING
ABLE TO SIGN ON A LOT MORE OF
OUR OWN PLAYERS AND WE HAD
THOUGHT GOING INTO IT AND
COMING BACK HERE AND WE STILL
PLAN ON HIM LEADING US AND
GETTING AS FAR AS WE CAN WITH
PLAN ON WE PLAN ON HE'S STILL
PART OF THE PLANS JOHN LYNCH
TRIED TO HOLD IT TOGETHER,
BUT HE WAS SLIDING OFF OF THE
HORSE AND GOT KYLE TO COME IN
AND SAVE HIM. I'M SORRY. I AM
A STUDENT OF DEMEANOR OF WORD
PATTERNS OF BODY LANGUAGE
EVERYTHING JOHN LYNCH WAS
TRYING HIS DAMNDEST TO SELL
US SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
INCAPABLE OF SELLING
THEMSELVES. NOBODY CAME OUT
AND SAID, HE'S OUR START OF
THIS YEAR ALL THESE
PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY. HE'S OUR
GUY THERE ARE GOD, HE'S OUR
GUY ANONYMOUS SOURCE. TELL
CHEF THE ON FRIDAY. HE'S
STILL OUR GUY DID EITHER OF
THEM SPEAK IT WITH THAT KIND
OF UNEQUIVOCAL ZEAL ABOUT
JIMMY GAROPPOLO TODAY. HELL
NO MILES. HELL. NO, HE'S
STILL IN THE PLANS AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THE PLAN IS TO TRY
TO GET SOME IDIOT TO TRADE
THEY SAID HE'S STOLEN THE
PLANS FOR THIS OFFSEASON, AND
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
EXACTLY IN THAT CLIP. BUT AT
SOME POINT IN THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE IS LITERALLY WHAT
THEY SAID THE OFFSEASON AND
IN THAT CLIP
THINK I'LL SHANAHAN USE THE
INFAMOUS WORDS RIGHT NOW. SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO OBVIOUSLY SEE HAPPEN
OVER THE COURSE OF WHETHER
IT'S BEFORE THE DRAFT DURING
THE DRAFT AFTER THE DRAFT AND
MAYBE RIGHT BEFORE THE SEASON
AFTER TRAINING CAMP AT SOME
POINT. I THINK THEY ARE
ANTICIPATING THAT JIMMY
GAROPPOLO WILL NOT BE ON THIS
TEAM FOR THE REST OF THE 2021
SEASON. IT JUST IT WOULD BE
PICKING IT BASICALLY BECAME
INEVITABLE FROM THE MOMENT
THAT THEY EXECUTED THAT TRADE
AND SAID WE'RE
GOING UP TO NUMBER-3 TO
SELECT THE QUARTERBACK. THEY
HAVE BEEN BASICALLY DECIDED
THAT JIMMY GAROPPOLO IS MORE
LIKELY THAN NOT NOT GOING TO
BE ON THE TEAM ANYMORE AT
SOME POINT BEFORE THE REGULAR
SEASON OR MAYBE DURING THE
REGULAR SEASON, BUT I THINK
IT SHOULD BE BEFORE THE
REGULAR SEASON BECAUSE
MILLION DOLLAR SALARY AND
IT'S GONNA COST THEM LESS
THAN THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DEBT CAP IF THEY JUST
STRAIGHT UP RELEASE HIM. SO
TO ME, THERE'S NOT MUCH.
THERE'S NOT MUCH SENSE IN
WHEN THAT'S THE KIND OF MATH
THAT IT IS AND ALSO YOUR
YOU'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE AT
SOME POINT YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY BELIEVE THAT
JIMMY GAROPPOLO IS THE
QUARTERBACK OF THE FUTURE.
OTHERWISE, YOU WOULDN'T TRADE
UP AND GIVE UP ALL THAT DRAFT
CAPITAL TO GET UP TO NUMBER
THREE IN THE FIRST PLACE MIKE.
YEAH. THAT'S THE ONE THING
THAT I CAN'T GET AWAY FROM IT.
I TRY TO KEEP THINGS AS
SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
ANYTHING MORE THAN THAT HURTS
MY BRAIN YOU GIVE UP THREE
FIRST-ROUND PICKS AND A
THIRD-ROUND PICK IN AN
IN ABOUT THREE FIRST-ROUND
PICKS FOR DESHAUN WATSON
THREE FIRST-ROUND PICKS
RUSSELL WILSON, YOU'RE NOT
INVESTING THREE ONES IN A
THREE FOR SOMEONE WHO'S GOING
TO HAVE HIS ASS PLANTED ON
THE BENCH FOR MULTIPLE YEARS,
OR EVEN FOR ONE YEAR I SAID
THIS TODAY ON 95 7 THE GAME
IN SAN FRANCISCO. IT'S LIKE
WHEN YOU GET A NEW TOY FOR
CHRISTMAS YOU GET A REMOTE
CONTROL CAR. WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO DO MILES AS SOON AS YOU
GET THE REMOTE CONTROL CAR?
DO YOU WANT TO KEEP IT IN THE
BOX FOR A YEAR, OR DO YOU
WANT TO TAKE THAT DAMN THING
OUTSIDE?
AND USE IT AND YOU'RE IN PAIN
I'M SPEAKING FROM EXPERIENCE.
YOU'RE IMPATIENT WHILE THE
DAMN BATTERY CHARGES CAN THE
BATTERY CHARGE FASTER. OH,
IT'S SNOWY AND IT'S ICY OUT.
MIGHT RUIN THE CAR. I DON'T
CARE. I'M
I AM WITH THIS DAMN CAR. I
WANTED IT. I GOT IT AND I'M
USING IT AND THAT'S THE
MENTALITY YOU DON'T MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT FOR A GUY THAT
ISN'T PART OF YOUR PLANS
RIGHT NOW. IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY SIMS IS CONVINCED
MAC JONES IS THE GUY BECAUSE
HE'S THE MOST GAME READY AND
YOU WOULDN'T GIVE UP THREE
ONES AND A 3 FOR A GUY THAT
YOU HAVE TO DEVELOP QUIETLY
BEHIND THE SCENES. YOU JUST
DON'T DO IT. YOU GET SOMEBODY
ELSE YOU STICK WITH JIMMY G
YOU TRADE FOR DESHAUN WATSON?
YEAH. I'M NOT THAT.
NOT THAT RUSSELL WILSON WOULD
BE TRADED BY THE SEAHAWKS TO
THE 49ERS, BUT IT'S NOT
UNPRECEDENTED. DONOVAN MCNABB
WAS TRADE IN THE DIVISION
DREW BLEDSOE IS TRADED IN THE
DIVISION. IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A
RULE. IT'S NOT A COMMANDMENT
THOU SHALT NOT TRADE A
QUARTERBACK WITHIN THE
DIVISION. SO YOU WANT
SOMEBODY MAKE AN IMPACT NOW
AND IT'S MAC JONES, I BELIEVE
AND HE'S STARTING THIS YEAR.
AND THE REST OF IT IS JUST
DETAILS DON'T GIVE ME THIS
STUFF THAT HE'S PLAYING IN
2021 AND MOZ. I DON'T KNOW
THAT I WANT HIM TO
AT THIS POINT.
IT'S TOO WEIRD RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE GOING TO BRING IN THIS
GUY WHO'S GONNA SUCK ALL THE
OXYGEN OUT OF THE ROOM,
RIGHT? YOU GOT TO MAKE HIM
THE GUY YOU'VE ALREADY TOLD
THE WORLD. THIS IS THE GUY
THIS IS THE FUTURE OF THE
FRANCHISE. THIS IS THE SAVIOR
OF THE SUPER BOWL POTENTIAL
WINNING 49ERS. YOU CAN'T
BRING HIM IN AND JUST PUT HIM
IN A CLOSET AND SLAM THE DOOR
AND SAY WELL WE'RE BRINGING
I THINK THE OTHER PART OF
THIS IT KIND OF JUST REMINDS
ME OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
EAGLES IN SIXTEEN WHEN THEY
DRAFTED CARSON WENTZ AND THEY
HAD SAM BRADFORD AND THEY
TALKED ABOUT SAM BRADFORD
BEING STARTER AND ALL THAT
FOR A REALLY LONG TIME AND I
BELIEVE IT WAS LABOR DAY
WEEKEND WHEN THEY FINALLY
TRADED HIM TO MINNESOTA AND
THEN FROM THERE ON IT'S LIKE
BOOM. YEAH. CARSON WENTZ IS
THE GUY CARSON WENTZ HAS
BEATEN OUT SAM BRADFORD
CARSON WENTZ HAS SHOWN ALL OF
THESE GREAT THINGS IN
TRAINING CAMP AND WE JUST
BELIEVE IN CARSON WENTZ AND
OBVIOUSLY FIVE YEARS
LATER. IT'S A TOTALLY
STORY, BUT AT THE TIME THAT'S
ALMOST FEEL LIKE THE 49ERS
ARE TRYING TO RUN THAT PLAY
BOOK. BASICALLY SAY, YES, WE
HAVE JIMMY GAROPPOLO. WE LIKE
JIMMY GAROPPOLO. WE THINK WE
CAN STILL WIN JIMMY GAROPPOLO
STILL GOING TO GIVE US THE
BEST CHANCE TO WIN AND THEN
THEY'RE HOPING THAT AT THE
END OF AUGUST. MAYBE THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME TEAM THAT'S
GOT A REALLY TERRIBLE
QUARTERBACK SITUATION AND
THEY ARE GOING TO WANT TO
BRING IN JIMMY GAROPPOLO AND
THEN THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE UP
IT'S LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW? BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
CONVINCE ME THAT THEY REALLY
REALLY BELIEVE THAT JIMMY
GAROPPOLO IS GOING TO BE THE
STARTING QUARTERBACK FOR THIS
TEAM THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
2021 SEASON. THAT'S NOT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU TRADE UP TO
DRAFT A GUY BELIEVING THAT HE
IS GOING TO BE YOUR FRANCHISE
QUARTERBACK MILES EXCELLENT
POINT AND THE NFL IS A
DEADLINE DRIVEN BUSINESS AS
FAR AS THE 49ERS ARE
CONCERNED WITH JIMMY
GAROPPOLO'S LONG AS THEY'RE
CONTENT TO HAVE THE 25
MILLION DOLLAR CAP CHARGER
RISING FROM HIS COMPENSATION
THIS YEAR
THE BACK.
BOOKS, THE DEADLINE IS THE
WEEKEND THE REGULAR SEASON
BEGINS. THAT'S WHEN AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER THE BASE
SALARY OF A VESTED VETERAN
BECOMES FULLY GUARANTEED.
WHAT HAPPENS IS IF YOU GOT
FOUR MORE YEARS OF SERVICE
AND YOU'RE ON THE ROSTER
ACTIVE ROSTER WEEK ONE AND YOU
GET CUT AT ANY POINT AFTER
THAT YOU CAN TAKE THE BALANCE
OF YOUR PAY UNREDUCED BUY
ANYTHING YOU EARN ELSEWHERE
TERMINATION PAY YOU HAVE ONE
25 MILLION IN PLAY JIMMY
GAROPPOLO WOULD DO IT. THAT'S
WHEN THE 49ERS NEED TO MAKE
THE DECISION TO I THINK AS
YOU SAID NOT THAT LONG AGO
POOR OR GET OFF THE POT SO
THAT GIVES THEM MONTHS MONTHS
TO HOLD ONTO JIMMY GAROPPOLO
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND YEAH
LOOK TEDDY BRIDGEWATER
CATASTROPHIC KNEE INJURY LATE,
AUGUST 2016 1
IN A FOR FALLS OUT OF THE SKY
FOR A GUY THAT THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE BENCHED AT SOME
POINT DURING THE 2016.
EVEN FOR CARSON WENTZ IF WENT
FIT AND START WEEK ONE, SO
THERE'S NO RUSH NONE
WHATSOEVER. UNLESS AND SEE
THIS IS WHY IT'S LIKE THE
TRENT BROWN SITUATION WITH
THE RAIDERS AND THE PATRIOTS
BECAUSE I WAS SURPRISED WHEN
TRENT BROWN AGREED TO TAKE
LESS MONEY AND THE PATRIOTS
TRADED FOR HIM BECAUSE IF
SAY TO THE RAIDERS, I'M NOT
REDUCING MY PAY. I'M NOT
CUTTING ME AND THEY SAY FARM
WILL CUT YOU WHEN WE FEEL
LIKE IT AND SO THE 49ERS CAN
HOLD ONTO JIMMY G UNTIL LABOR
DAY WEEKEND OR
SOMEONE CAN WORK.
OUT A DEAL WHERE THEY GIVE THE
49 OR SOMETHING AND JIMMY G
TAKES LESS MONEY AND THEY DO
THE TRADE NOW AND THEY JUST
SIT BACK AND WAIT FOR THAT
BUT NO ONE'S PAYING THIS GUY
25 MILLION THIS YEAR. IT'S
NOT HAPPENING FOLKS 25
MILLION IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WITH A REDUCED CAP FOR A GUY.
WHO'S MISS 23 GAMES OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS. IT WOULD BE
IDIOCY FOR THE 49ERS TO PAY
HIM 25 MILLION. SO I THINK
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE. I
THINK THAT IF ANYTHING TODAY
BELOW IS GOING TO BE ON THAT
ROSTER WEEK ONE UNLESS HE
AGREES TO A SIGNIFICANT PAY
CUT AND POTENTIALLY ISN'T THE
STARTER TO BEGIN THE SEASON
OR IF HE STARTS THE SEASON
HE'S GOING TO BE SUPPLANTED.
NOT LONG AFTER THAT LETS HEAR
KYLE SHANAHAN TALKING ABOUT
ATTENDING ALABAMA PRO DAY TWO.
THEY HAD PRO DAY ONE LAST
WEEK MAC JONES THROUGH HE'S
THROWING AGAIN TOMORROW AND
I NORMALLY DON'T LIKE TO GO
I NEED I HAVE TO UNLESS THEY
HAVE TO FOR SOME REASON BUT I
ALSO HAVE BEEN KIND OF GROWN
UP IN THE IDEA THAT YOU DON'T
LIKE TO GO EVERYWHERE AND
SHOW PEOPLE THINGS AND WHEN
YOU'RE SITTING AT 12 AND
STUFF, I DON'T WANT TO GO TO
A BUNCH OF QUARTERBACK PRO
DAYS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HIDE AS REE,
MUCH IT'S NOT AS BIG OF A
BEEN WHEN WERE SITTING AT 12.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE GUY
WHOSE DAD DRAFTED JAY CUTLER
IN 2006 AND HAD NEVER DONE
ANYTHING TO CREATE ANY
IMPRESSION THAT HE WAS IN ANY
WAY INTERESTED IN JAY CUTLER.
NO VISITS NO INTERVIEWS. NO
MEETINGS. IT WAS OUT OF THE
BLUE AND I THINK THE BRONCOS
TRADED UP WITH THE RAMS IF
I'M CORRECT, AND THERE IS A
VERY STRONG CHANCE. I'M NOT
THAT YOU HAVE TO ENGAGE IN
PRIOR TO THE DRAFT BECAUSE
YOU DO ANYTHING YOU SAY WILL
BE USED AGAINST YOU IN THIS
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT OF
PEOPLE GETTING THE GUYS THEY
WANT. SO NOW THAT THEY HOLD
THE THIRD PICK BECAUSE
SOMEBODY MADE THE ARGUMENT
OWE HIM. OH, THIS IS A
SMOKESCREEN. YOU REALLY WANT
ZACH WILSON NOT WHAT WOULD
KNOW NOT WORRY REALLY WANTS
JUSTIN FIELDS. NO, NO ONE CAN
GET THEM AND IF THE ONLY WAY
THEY'RE GOING TO GET FIELDS
ARE JUN'S IS TO GET IN FRONT
OF YOU. AND THAT MEANS YOU'RE
GOING TO GET TREVOR LAWRENCE
OR ZACH WILSON. IT'S A
NO-LOSE PROPOSITION AND I
HAVE TO BE COY ABOUT
ANYTHING AT THIS POINT MILES
EXACTLY AND THAT'S WHY WHEN
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT IN
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY.
THEY SAID THAT THERE ARE
THREE GUYS THAT THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH AND BY GOING
UP TO THREE THEY GIVE
GUARANTEED THEMSELVES ONE OF
THOSE THREE GUYS. AND SO
THAT'S WHY IT REALLY DOESN'T
MATTER. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE THE SMOKESCREEN LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING MIKE YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU WANT
TO DO TO FEEL AS COMFORTABLE
AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN ABOUT
WHOEVER YOU'RE GOING TO
SELECT TO BE THIS FRANCHISE
QUARTERBACK FOR THE NEXT
HOWEVER MANY YEARS AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN A
YEAR LIKE THIS WHERE KYLE
SHANAHAN TALK ABOUT THIS. YOU
CANNOT GO AND REALLY HAVE A
PRIVATE WORKOUT WITH A GUY AS
YOU NORMALLY WOULD YOU CAN GO
AND SIT DOWN AND HAVE DINNER
WITH A GUY AS YOU NORMALLY
WOULD SO INSTEAD YOU SEE
THINGS LIKE WHAT URBAN MEYER
DID DOWN THERE AT CLEMSON
DURING THAT WHEN THEY HE HAD
THAT PRO DEBUT FOR TREVOR
LAWRENCE WRIGHT, YOU KNOW, HE
WAS JUST STANDING THERE. SO
CLOSE TO HIM SO HE COULD HEAR
THE HUM OF THE BALL COMING
OUT OF HIS HAND AND ALL THAT
NOISE. SO I THINK WHEN YOU
ARE ABLE TO THEN JUST SAY YES.
YES, WE'RE GOING DOWN THERE
BECAUSE WE'RE INTERESTED IN
TAKING A QB AND IT COULD
YOU'RE JUST BASICALLY YOU'RE
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY ALL THE
MYSTERY TO IT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT YOU CAN
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER AND I
LIKE WE WERE SAYING LAST
FRIDAY. I THINK IT WAS IF THE
JETS DON'T WANT ZACH WILSON
THEN I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE THAT SOMEBODY
IS GOING TO HAVE TO PRY THAT
PICK FROM THEIR COLD DEAD
HANDS. SO AND I DON'T THINK
THAT URBAN MEYER WOULD EVEN
EVER COME TO JACKSONVILLE IF
THERE WASN'T A CHANCE OF THEM
DRAFTING TREVOR LAWRENCE, SO
THEY BASICALLY KNOW WHAT THE
BE IF SOMETHING HAPPENS,  TO
THEY'RE STILL COMFORTABLE
WITH WHOEVER IS GOING TO BE
HEY MOZ, I SUGGESTED EARLIER
DAY ON PFT LIVE AND THEY PUT
UP THE CONSPIRACY MY GRAPHIC
WHEN I SAID THIS BUT I DON'T
THINK IT'S MUCH OF A
CONSPIRACY THE IDEA THAT
URBAN MEYER DELIBERATELY
DIDN'T GO TO ZACH WILSON'S
PRO DAY BECAUSE HE DOES NOT
WANT ANY DOUBT CREEPING IN
HE'S ALL-IN ON TREVOR
LAWRENCE AND IF HE WOULD HAVE
STOOD THERE MASK ON NOSE OUT
WATCHING AND LISTENING TO THE
BALL. COME OUT EXACT WILSON'S
LEFT LEFT TO RIGHT TO LEFT
AND THROWING BACK ACROSS HIS
BODY. MAYBE HE WOULD HAVE
STARTED THINKING ARE WE SURE
THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
FOR US TO DO?
AND THERE IT IS. LET ME JUST
GRAPHIC WITHIN THE PAST
AN EMAIL FROM ONE OF OUR GOT
VIEWERS IN THE UK WHO SAID I
DIDN'T KNOW YOU SMOKED
CIGARETTES. OKAY, THAT'S
THAT'S EITHER SOMEBODY WHO
KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT AMERICAN
POP CULTURE OR AN EXCELLENT
NOT WEAR SHORT SLEEVED DRESS
SHIRTS. SO THAT'S YOUR
ULTIMATE PROOF. NOR DO I
SMOKE CIGARETTES CIGARS.
ONCE OR TWICE A WEEK, YES
CIGARETTES. NO, I WAS RIGHT
BY THE WAY SOMEHOW SOME WAY
THE BRONCOS 2006. THEY HAD
PICKED NUMBER 15 A PACKAGE 15
AND 68 TO THE THEN ST. LOUIS
RAMS TO MOVE UP TO 11 TO GET
JAY CUTLER AND STUNNED
EVERYONE. THAT WAS MIKE
SHANAHAN KYLE LEARNING FROM
HIS DAD HOW TO BE SECRETIVE
AND YOU DON'T NEED TO BE
SECRETIVE NOW AND HERE HE IS.
YOU MENTIONED SOME OF THE
THINGS ABOUT THE MIKE JONES
DYNAMIC WITH KYLE SHANAHAN
SHANAHAN FROM EARLIER TODAY.
TALKING ABOUT THE FORMER,
ALABAMA QUARTERBACK
THE WAY WE LOOKED AT IT AS I
MEAN TO MOVE UP TO 3, WE HAD
THREE GUYS WE'D BE HERE'S
TEAM FOR A LONG TIME AND WE
COULDN'T MAKE THAT DECISION
BEFORE THERE WAS THREE GUYS,
WE HAD TO FEEL THAT WAY WITH
THREE NOW. I THINK THERE'S A
CHANCE TO GET THERE WITH FOUR
AND FIVE. THERE'S A CHANCE
THERE'S FIVE GUYS ARE KIND OF
AT THIS PARTY A LITTLE BIT
AND PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THEM GOING EVERYWHERE.
THEY'RE ALL OVER IN THE FIRST
ROUND. OUR FEELING IS THESE
GUYS WERE GOING TO GO A LOT
HIGHER THAN PEOPLE REALIZE
AND WHEN YOU HAVE TWO GUYS,
SITTING OUT ONE AND TO
POSSIBLY COULD EVEN POSSIBLY
THREE AND FOUR, THEN YOU HEAR
A LOT OF TEAMS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE DRAFT TO ARE IN
SITUATION WHERE THEY REALLY
WANT A QUARTERBACK AND THEY
DON'T HAVE SOMEONE CLOSE TO
WHAT WE HAVE WITH JIMMY. THAT
MEANS THOSE FIVE GUYS GOING
TO DISAPPEAR PRETTY FAST. SO
WE HAD TO FEEL CONFIDENT AND
THREE TO MAKE THIS MOVE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DID AND I DO A
MAN EXCITED ABOUT NOW, WE
KNOW THERE'S FIVE PLAYERS.
WHO DO YOU WANT TO PUT YOUR
HOODIE WANT TO PREDICT YOUR
FUTURE IN?
WELL THATTHAT WELL LOOK I NTH
THINK PART OF IT TOO. THEY
ALL GET THE MEMO OFFICIALLY
OR UNOFFICIALLY NOT TO
DISRUPT THE ELEMENT OF
SURPRISE. I THINK THEY KNOW
DAMN WELL WHO THEY WANT AT
THIS POINT. IT'S JUST
CHECKING BOXES CONFIRMATION.
HEY, LOOK ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN
BETWEEN NOW AND A MONTH FROM
NOW. I DON'T WANT TO THROW
OUT POSSIBILITIES. I DON'T
WANT TO THROW OUT
POSSIBILITIES. I DON'T WANT
HAPPEN.
TO MAKE MAC JONES ALL OF A
SUDDEN NOT ATTRACTIVE A MONTH
FROM NOW. THERE ARE A VARIETY
KITCHEN ACCIDENTS CAN HAPPEN.
THAT WOULD MAKE MAC JONES,
YOU KNOW, NOT ATTRACTIVE NINE
FINGERS INSTEAD OF 10. FOR
MAKES MAC JONES NOT
OF THE FINGERS MISSING IS ON
HIS THROWING HAND SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO SAY ANYTHING
AND THE LEAGUE DOESN'T WANT
YOU TO SAY ANYTHING UNTIL THE
PICK COMES IN. BUT I THINK
THEY KNOW MILES WHO THEY
WANT. THEY
MAKE THIS MOVE WITHOUT KNOWING
WHO THEY WHAT WE GET THE
BOARD AFTER THE FIRST TWO
PICS ARE GONE. THEY KNOW WHO
THEY WANTED. THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE GIVEN UP THAT MUCH TO
GET THERE. NO DOUBT IT. I'LL
WORK FOR THE RAMS IN 2016
WHEN THEY TRADED UP TO GET
JARED GOFF AND AT THE TIME
EVERYBODY KEPT SAYING, OH,
WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S THIS
PERCENTAGE OR THAT PERCENTAGE
OR WE'RE STILL GONNA BE ABLE
TO DIVE IN HERE AND REALLY
MAKE A DECISION. THEY KNEW
WHO THEY WANTED WHEN THEY
MADE THE TRADE AND YOU DON'T
TRADE UP TO NUMBER.
ONE OVERALL UNLESS YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHO YOU WANT. OKAY,
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
BECAUSE THEY PROBABLY HAVE
VERY GOOD INTEL ON WHO WAS
GOING AT NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO OVERALL THE 49ERS
TRADED UP TO NUMBER THREE
OVERALL BECAUSE THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE GUY IS GOING TO
BE ON THE BOARD AND THEN THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PICK THAT GUY. I
THINK YOU COULD ACTUALLY SAY
THE SAME THING ABOUT THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES IN 2016.
THEY HAD A FEELING PRETTY
GOOD FEELING OF WHO THE RAMS
WERE GOING TO TAKE A NUMBER
ONE OVERALL. SO THAT'S WHY
THEY FELT COMFORTABLE GOING UP
NUMBER 200.
ROLL WITH THE BROWNS AND THEN
THEY SELECTED CARSON WENTZ.
THERE'S JUST THERE'S JUST TOO
MUCH CERTAINTY IN THESE
SITUATIONS THAT I FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE WHEN YOU'RE
THAT IS GOING TO BE BASICALLY
RIGHT, YOU YOU CANNOT JUST DO
THIS THINKING WELL IF THIS OR
THEN MAYBE WE CAN DO BLAH
BLAH. NO, YOU HAVE TO BE
PRETTY CERTAIN IN ORDER TO DO
THIS AND THAT'S WHY I REALLY
FEEL LIKE THESE GUYS IN THE
49ERS ORGANIZATION ARE
EXTREMELY CERTAIN AT STOOD
WHY?
THE FACT THAT HE ENJOYED LOVE
EVERY DAY EVERY HOUR EVERY
MINUTE AND EVERY SECOND OF
HAVING THE FIRST PICK AND NOT
TELLING ANYONE WHO WHAT WAS
GOING TO BE AND YOU KNOW,
TRYING TO OVER HIS MOUTH AND
YOU'D SEE THE BE KIND OF A
HALF SMILE HIDING BEHIND
THEIR YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BEHIND THAT
MUSTACHE. HE LOVED IT. HE
LOVED IT. WE ALL KNEW IT WAS
JARED GOFF, BUT HE LOVED IT
AND LOOK. I DON'T KNOW THIS
BUT COMMON SENSE TELLS ME THE
LEAGUE OFFICE HAMMERS INTO
THE TEAM THAT HAS THE FIRST
OVERALL PICK IN THE DRAFT. DO
DO NOT DISCLOSE WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT TWO TYPES OF FANS
OUT THERE. YOU'VE GOT THE
PEOPLE WHO PAY ATTENTION TO
IT ALL THE TIME AND KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON
BECAUSE THEY'RE SOAKING UP
EVERY BIT OF INFORMATION
THOSE PEOPLE KNOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE TREVOR LAWRENCE
IS GOING NUMBER ONE OF THE
JAGUARS THEN YOU GOT ALL
THESE FOLKS WHO ARE JUST KIND
OF CASUAL WHO SHOW UP.
FOR BIG EVENTS LIKE THE SUPER
BOWL AND THE DRAFT MORE SHOW
UP FOR THE SUPER BOWL, BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM TO SHOW
UP FOR THE DRAFT. THEY DON'T
KNOW THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING.
SO IF YOU SAY IT AND IT
BECOMES THE ABOVE THE FOLD
HEADLINE ON THE SPORTS PAGE
IF THERE ARE EVEN SPORTS
PAGES ANYMORE AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS ABOUT IT GETS BLASTED
OUT. EVERYONE'S PHONE.
THERE'S NO MYSTERY WHATSOEVER.
EVEN IF IT'S A LITTLE
MYSTERY THEY LIKED IT. SO I
THINK THAT SAME THING APPLIES
APPLIES TO THE 49ERS AT 3,
AND EVERYONE'S PLAYING ALONG
TO MAKE THE DRAFT A BIGGER
DEAL A LITTLE BIT.
MYSTERY EVEN IF THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE ANY SURPRISE
LAWRENCE WILSON AND JONES.
MAYBE NOT MAYBE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO COME OUT AND SAY
THEY DON'T HAVE TO KNOW THEY
DON'T HAVE TO AND THEY
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T IT, YOU
KNOW, IT'S BETTER FOR US.
MAYBE IF THEY DON'T DO IT,
YOU KNOW, AND THEN THE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO FIGURE OUT ON
DRAFT NIGHT. OH, WOW, LIKE
THEY DRAGGED SLOWLY DRAFTED
MATT JONES OR OH, WELL, THEY
FINALLY DRAFTED TREVOR
LAWRENCE OR EXACT WILSON AND
THEN THEY COME TO PRO
FOOTBALL TALK AND THEY READ
OUR ARTICLES ABOUT IT. SO I
GUESS IT IS, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES BETTER FOR US,
YEAH. HEY, THAT'S THE WAY IT
GOES. WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
MYSTERY DRAWN OUT AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
BE TRANSPARENT WITH THE
AUDIENCE BECAUSE I MEAN I
THIS IS WHERE IT GETS A
LITTLE BIT DICEY BECAUSE
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME TWEETS
RECENTLY. THERE WERE DELETED
BY FOLKS WHO WORK FOR THE
SHIELD BECAUSE MAYBE THOSE
TWEETS WERE A LITTLE TOO
CLOSE TO THE MARK OF LETTING
EVERYONE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. THIS GETS
INTO THE HOLE. DON'T TIP THE
PICS THAT JUST NOT ON DRAFT.
THAT WORKS AHEAD OF TIME AS
THEY DON'T WANT ANY CERTAINTY
CLARITY. THEY WANT THERE TO
BE JUST ENOUGH EQUIVOCATION.
SO WE TUNE IN BECAUSE YOU
NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
GOING TO HAVE A VIDEO POSTED
ON TO THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNT BY A HACKER WITH
RIGHT? I MEAN ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN THE CRAZIEST STUFF YOU
CAN IMAGINE CAN STILL HAPPEN.
ALL RIGHT, MAC JONES RECENTLY
ADDRESSED THE POSSIBILITY OF
PLAYING FOR THE 49ERS
SPECIFICALLY.
49ERS OFFENSE HERE'S JONES ON
SAN FRANCISCO. I'VE WATCHED
YOUR TAPE AND STUFF. I'VE GOT
A CHANCE TO WATCH A LOT OF
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY BUT 49ER
SPECIFICALLY OBVIOUSLY THEY
RUN A LOT OF WIDE ZONE. THEY
SO THEY CAN RUN POWER AND K
PASS OFF OF THAT. SO OUTSIDE
ZONE SPRING OUT STUFF, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
DROPPED BACK PASSING GAME IS
REALLY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID
WITH SARK AND YOU KNOW, SOME
OF THE EMOTIONS THAT THEY USE
I NOTICED THEY GOT THE
BOOMERANG MOTIONS AND THE CAP
ALL FAST, SO THAT'S ALL STUFF
THAT I'M REALLY FAMILIAR WITH
AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S A SUPER
QUARTERBACK FRIENDLY OFFENSE,
AND THEY HAVE GREAT
PLAYMAKERS THERE. SO I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
OH AND HE WILL OH HE WILL.
IT'S JUST HE NEEDS TO BE A
REST OF THEM. AND AGAIN, HEY
LOOK TOMORROW, WHO KNOWS WHAT
HAPPENS AT HIS PRO DAY
WORKOUT NUMBER TWO, BUT
SHANAHAN WILL BE THERE LYNCH
WILL BE THERE CHECK THE BOX,
RIGHT? THIS GUY WON THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP. HE
KNOWS HOW TO PERFORM UNDER
PRESSURE. HE'LL HAVE A LITTLE
PRESSURE TOMORROW TO PERFORM
WITH THIS PRESUMPTION THAT
HE'S GOING TO BE THE PICK OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ERS AT
NUMBER THREE OVERALL NUMBER
SIX OVERALL QUITE POSSIBLY
DEVANTE SMITH TO THE MIAMI
DOLPHINS IN THE DOLPHINS BY
UP ARE STILL IN POSITION TO K
PROBABLY GET THE GUY THEY
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN IT NUMBER POT